c'est une halle de marché provisoire qui
s'est installée place riboud à mort par
une implantation suite à l'incendié de
l'ancienne halle en 2019 sa remplaçante
devrait voir le jour à l'horizon 2024 un
projet en concertation depuis 2020
auprès des habitants des commerçants et
des élus samedi les morts pas bien
pouvez découvrir les plants et l'
architecture de la future halle
aujourd'hui voilà on monte le concret on
pourra faire évidemment encore des
ajustements puisque la concertation avec
que les mauraciens sert à ça et puis
après on lancera les marchés de travaux
franchement le design super beau tout
neuf vraiment ouais c'est vraiment pas
mal à un petit port ça va être un petit
peu de ton mais c'est pas mal j'ai vu
quand l'ancien à bollée c'était bien
dommage heureusement ils ont mille sain
et c'est très bien qu'il leur fasse et
ça a l'air assez moderne en plus donc
c'est très bien précieux trouve assez
design quand même très épuré tout en
bois je pense avec des matériaux
écologiques
la nouvelle halle elle est magnifique
aussi et je pense que nous allons avoir
beaucoup plus de clients si l'ancienne
halle et est ouverte avec des étals
amovible le nouvel espace de 1500 mètres
carrés devraient accueillir 20 étals
fixes destinées aux commerçants
alimentaires des étals qui soient
pérennes une nouvelle ferme et plus
sécurisé avec des toilettes publiques
également c'est une demande aussi de
mort croisiens la nouvelle halle sera
tournée vers le développement durable on
aura des panneaux photovoltaïques sur le
toit pour nous permettre d'avoir une
énergie propre on va pouvoir avoir un
bac aussi de récupération d'eau de pluie
pour pouvoir faire l'arrosage des
espaces verts et donc on pense le projet
à long terme le projet a nécessité 18
mois de travaux livraison prévue début
2011 24